so right now Don jr. and Russia
that's the scandal this was being
discussed on CNN between Chris DNC pool
boy
Cuomo and Kellyanne Conlon here's what's
important before this portion of the
interview I encourage you to go watch
the whole interview it's about 34
minutes long Chris Cuomo is just saying
Donald Trump jr. Donald Trump jr. said
it himself he said it himself he met
with this Russian lawyer to discuss
tacking that's how he's setting it up
and then finally this is what happens no
you got to give the whole statement to
be fair to him and to be fair to your
viewers let's stop chopping it up he
ventures viral with his nominal put the
statement of the other one is parsing I
mean okay bring it out it up Marcos
clean it up with the statement of after
pleasantries were exchanged the woman
stated that she had information that
individuals connected to Russia his word
were funding the Democratic National
Committee and supporting MS Clinton her
CIA ended their big ambiguous and made
no sense no details or supporting
information was provided oh yeah or even
offered it quickly became clear she had
no meaningful information
oh is a context change that anything
here's what's important with the Trump
Russia scandal I'm not saying that there
couldn't be something happening with
Trump remorse I'm certainly not saying
that there's nobody in his cabinet
nobody in the people in the group of
folks who ran his campaign who might
have unsavory ties to Russia that's not
what I'm saying when it comes to the
media and their handling of the Russia
scandal this is a constant through line
and this is this is why it is important
if you read a debate book or if you
watch a ben shapiro uh HBO seminar there
will be tactics certainly ways to lead
questions there will be rules like don't
ever ask a question you don't know the
answer to kind of same thing as legal
tactics when you're actually litigating
okay something that is not in the
rulebook is all right just bring up the
full transcript just pretend you know
why it's not a technique it's not a
tactic it only works when you say just
bring up the full transcript if you know
that you're telling the truth and your
opponent is lying that's the only way it
works no one is saying oh I'm going to
cut them off the pass no it's listen I
know you're lying just show what he said
and then that happened it is constant
unnamed sources anonymous by lines that
come up with stories that then
turn out to be if not complete
falsehoods certainly being tweaked
certainly being massaged to try and
create another Russia scandal and that's
why if you look at the studies there's a
state of [ __ ] they've spent an
inordinate amount of time on Russia the
media certainly more than on issues that
most Americans care about if you pull
them like the economy like health care
they spend a huge amount of time I'm not
sure why we'll talk about that at the
end of this segment
also by the way I with Chris coma this
is that hominem I get it my only one
that finds when he is conducting an
interview he always looks as though he
is surprised by a sudden urge and then
panicked to go to the bathroom first of
all if you were know if you were an IRA
for boy is it yes that's the coffee can
in have to take it out have to dig it
out have to go can I make it to the
commercial break is it eight minutes
maybe it's seven I can make it if it's
five I gotta go oh it's four okay I can
definitely make it four minutes gotta go
I don't think you can make it four
minutes so okay let's go through a
timeline here it isn't important because
Don Donald Trump jr. won't even be if we
were to do a timeline of Trump and
Russia six months from now this is a
blip it won't even be on the radar we to
try and condense this down from hundreds
to a handful just to point out how many
scandals have been falsified that you've
forgotten about first one obviously was
when in the campaign the accused Donald
Trump of hacking the DNC remember it's
Russia he was colluding with Russia and
he hacked the DNC and Podesta was
singing singing this from the rooftop as
loud as he could no it turned out that
Podesta actually just fell victim to a
phishing email because he's a [ __ ] and
his password allegedly was password
January tenth BuzzFeed they said that
Russia has compromising dirt on Donald
Trump like sex tapes in contact with
Russian hookers this was you know this
is a whole he would pay Russian
prostitutes to pee on furniture I guess
we always thought it was from some kind
of water sport venture when Donald Trump
and Russia prostitutes film showers what
was the truth the truth was that it was
a report prepared by retired British
intelligence officer as specifically
opposition research for Trump opponents
and by the way he was unnamed at first
and turned out to be completely US this
was not new information it was something
was compiled for the campaign
turned out to be completely yes let's go
to another claim clean number three may
9th in the New York Times they said that
Comey was fired because Trump tried to
stop an ongoing investigation this was
weeks weeks wall-to-wall coverage the
truth Comey said in his own hearing that
Trump never even asked him to drop the
Russia investigation and they ran with
this again unnamed sources saying that
he was fired in reason that this matters
so much because one thing that you'll
understand is is as you watch me you
know it's really expensive to actually
do investigative reporting it's really
expensive to actually go and dig for
news it's a lot hyper and it's a lot
more profitable to just put a panel
together to talk about something let's
go to claim number four this is May 10th
they said that Rosenstein Rose
Rosenstein Rosenstein threatened to quit
after Trump fired Comey according again
to an unnamed source this was in
Washington Post what was the truth Rosen
Stein himself said they never threatened
equipment a lot of CNN and BuzzFeed in
Washington so let's look at another
claim number five this was May 15th
Trump revealed classified information to
the Russians during the meetings with
Lavrov and kiss lyac according to an
anonymous source look man try to put the
Russian lilt on me I get another
anonymous source this was Washington
Post the truth people who were there
McMaster Tillerson deputy of national
security advisor Dina Powell all denied
the report now is there some he-said
she-said sure but they didn't run with
that they relevant of the fact and
there's people who have first-hand
knowledge that no no that's not true
number 6 June 14th again Washington Post
Trump is under investigation for
obstruction of justice
according to yet again an unnamed source
we don't know if it's true
you think we don't know if this is true
because the white Washington Post is
once again using an unnamed source we've
talked about this with James O'Keefe
sometimes you have to protect your
sources if their life is in jeopardy but
they're not in jeopardy here and it's
always an anonymous source it's always
some byline with no one attached to it
and Trump's lawyers deny that the
president of an under investigation at
all so they want to present this idea
that Donald Trump is directly under
investigation because of ties with
Russia and colluding to hack the
election they have provided no proof no
substantiative proof whatsoever and it
is a constantly moving target we've had
liberal guests on the show or they go
home now that was wrong the BuzzFeed
thing or the fake
she was wrong but what about just
happened this week what about Comey
we've had them on the show when that
happened and it's hard for us to refute
it because we said we don't know if any
of that's true well an unnamed source
says it and then ultimately what is the
undoing of all of these Trump Russia
scandals unnamed source the undoing is
transparency the undoing is more like
that's the big difference
sunlight is the best disinfectant you
can see that right-wingers conservatives
they truly believe that when it comes to
Trump right now the left is constantly
operating in the dark because they
require it and every single scandal I
just named you was salt we got to the
truth when there was more transparency
and we were given more information
that's why someone like Kellyanne Conway
can say oh you know what why don't you
run the full transcript that's all we
can just say oh really
let's go to the tale of the tape you
don't even need to argue you don't need
to be a skilled debater you just need to
wait for the facts to come out and
that's why people don't trust the media
anymore and that's why we continually
have unnamed sources and unsubstantiated
claims about Donald Trump and Russia
because what happens well when CNN
starts losing in the cable news ratings
again to all other networks and even
Bill Cosby reruns on Nick at night quick
quick hurry it's time to fabricate
another fake Russia scandal like this
video subscribe by clicking the
subscribe button it's Achatz aniseh
circle now used to be a square which
most buttons aren't squares what sits on
a phone they're square buttons on phones
what most buttons are circles you
understand what I'm talking about or
what's the recommended video which is
popping up in a box or subscribe at
lateral clutter calm flash mug club join
them on clip so you can get the Daily
Show and that means that you are not
beholden to the YouTube censoring
overlords let's be honest you like being
there where you are under their thumb
power bottom you